[Musique]
quand la population canadienne est elle
devenue majoritairement urbaine dans les
années 1920 alors qu'à ses débuts le
canada s'est bâtie à grands coups de
hache et de hertz au 19e siècle le pays
s'industrialise les cultivateurs
quittent leurs terres pour travailler
dans des usines et dans les années 1920
un seuil historique est franchie
cinquante pour cent des canadiens sont
désormais chez eux en ville une tendance
qui ne fera que s'accentuer au fil du
temps aujourd'hui plus de 80 % des
canadiens vivent en zone urbaine le
déclin de la population rurale s'est
accompagné d'un autre phénomène la
diminution du nombre de fermes on en
comptait 700 milles en 1941 un sommet
aujourd'hui elles sont deux cent mille
mais pour la première fois depuis
plusieurs décennies le nombre de fermes
a légèrement augmenté en 2020 au québec
il s'agit principalement d'entreprises
de petite taille dans le secteur
maraîcher notamment en retour à la terre
que la copine pourrait peut-être
favorisé